ننوه الان الى هذا الخبر العاجل حيث قال
مراسل الجزيره ان قصفا عنيفا اسرائيليا
استهدف مناطق عده في خانيونس جنوبي قطاع
غزه ومن هناك ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
اسماعيل ابو عمره ابو عمر اذا ما الذي
رصدته من تطورات في خانيونس مع ارتفاع حده
القصف العنيف لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه ن القصف العنيف يتركز الاجزاء
الغربيه من محافظه خانيونس حيث تتواجد
اليات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فعليا في معسكر
خانيونس وكذلك غرب هذا المعسكر وتقوم هذه
الاليات باطلاق قذاف مدفعيه بين الحين
والاخر في محيط مستشفى ماصر في غرب محافظه
خانيونس اضافه الى ان عده الغارات التي
شنت خلال الساعات الماضيه منذ صباح امس
وحتى هذه اللحظه ادت الى ارتقاء اكثر من
50 شهيد في محافظه الانوس اضافه الى 120
اصابه تعاملت معها الاقب الطبيه داخل مجمع
ناصر الطبي اضافه الى ان بعض الشهداء تم
نقلهم الى مستشفى ابو يوسف النجار في
مدينه رفح جنوب القطعه الغارات
الاسرائيليه تركزت في الاجزاء الغربيه
اضافه الى ان احزمه ناريه نفذتها طائرات
الاحتلال وقامت باطلاق صواريخ باتجاه
اهداف عديده في المناطق الشرقيه ايضا
لمحافظه خان يونس في حين ان هذه المناطق
الشرقيه
خفت تواجد اليات الاحتلال فيها وتوا
الاليات الان في المناطق الغربيه لكن هذا
لا لم يمنع قوات الاحتلال وطارت الاحتلال
من اطلاق صواريخها باتجاه اهداف ع في
المناطقه الشرقيه ونفذت ايضا احزم ناريه
كما قامت قوات الاحتلال بعمليات نفف عديده
وكثيره في المنطقه الوسطى لمحافظه خيوس في
وسط المحافظه وهذا هو يعني ما قامت به
خلال الساعات الماضيه في اكثر من منطقه
سواء في شرق خانيونس وكذلك في وسط خانيونس
اضافه الى منطقه غرب خانيونس وعديد
الغارات ما زالت تنفس بين الحين والاخر
اضافه القصف المدفعي في محيط مستشفى خاص
في المحافظه اليات الاحتلال التواجد الان
في بالقرب من مسجد خالد بن الوليد في
معسكر خان يونس وهذا المعسكر
مكتر المساكن والبنايات السكنيه وهو عباره
عن مخيم للاجئين ووجود اليات الاحتلال في
تلك المنطقه خاصه ان نتحدث بان المنطقه
تحتوي على مدارس تاوين نازحين بالعديد
والالاف من النازحين في المنطقه لم
يستطيعوا الخروج من المنطقه بسبب حده
القصف المدفع الذي كانت تنفذه اليات
الاحتلال في اكثر من محور محاور القتال
ويصعب على الم التحرك في تلك المناطق بسبب
شده القصف المدفع الذي قامت به الاحتلال
خلال الساعات الماضيه واطلاق النار هناك
عديد الشهداء كان بين الزعين خلال تنقلهم
من منطقه خانس باتجاه منطقه رفح او منطقه
دير البلح في وس في خانيونس غرب خانيونس
نظرا لان قوات الاحتلال واليات الاحتلال
قامت بخلال الساعات الماضيه باغلاق بعض
الشوارع التي تؤدي الى منطقه غرب خانيونس
ومن تلك المنطقه تتجه او يتجه المواطنون
منطقه رفح وكذلك منطقه دير البلح